welcome back okay
we're finally ready to design a
coordinate transformation T that
balances our grants
okay so up until now what we've done is
we've taken this original system we've
shown how those dynamics transform under
a coordinate transformation from X to Z
we've also looked at how the graeme is
the controllability and observability
grampians change so this is my
controllability and observability graeme
and in my original x coordinates and
they transform into these new hats
graeme ins in my Z coordinates according
to this set of formulas and now what
we're trying to do what Moore showed in
1981 and what we're gonna do is we're
going to design a very very special t
matrix so that we take our original
controllability and observability graeme
ins and in these new t coordinates in
these hat coordinates we're going to get
them to be balanced which means that
they're equal and diagonal and that's
eventually so in the next phase we're
going to use those balanced graeme ins
to chop off and truncate our SAR huge
high dimensional state and only pick the
the modes the directions in state space
that are most jointly controllable and
observable in this case this big pink
direction and that will allow us to get
an input-output model in terms of a much
smaller state X that still captures most
of the dynamics okay so what we're gonna
do right now is we're going to
essentially find this coordinate
transformation so we're going to find
the coordinate transformation T so that
in that transform coordinates my new
Graham Ian's are going to be W C equals
W o hat equals Sigma now Sigma is kind
of my go-to notation for a diagonal
matrix because of the singular value
decomposition okay so this is actually
pretty related to singular value
decomposition but this is just a
diagonal matrix and the entries of Sigma
go from biggest to smallest so the first
column of WC hat is the most
controllable direction most observable
direction the second one is your Sigma
is smaller so the second column is the
second most controllable and observable
and so on and so forth okay go back to
the control bootcamp and refresh
yourself on what the the Grammy uns mean
physically because I'm assuming that you
know that these Grammy uns essentially
tell me what directions and state space
are most controllable and observable the
columns of this literally tell me in
order what's the most to least
controllable and observable directions
on the state space okay okay good or
really the columns of T so this is what
we want and now what we're going to do
is I'm just going to take a product of
these two Grammys I'm going to multiply
them so we're gonna do some math and
eventually we're going to come out to an
expression that will allow me to solve
for T to get these gradients so first of
all let's just multiply these WC hat x
wo hat and what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to use this expression and this
expression so WC hat x wo hat is T
inverse WC t minus star T star wot
sounds like a lot okay let's write that
out that's equal to t inverse WC now T
inverse star times T star is the
identity so I'm not going to write those
I'm just going to write wo T so I
skipped a step here where this times
this is the identity so this times this
those middle matrices cancel out and
this is what I get that's pretty nice
now what we're going to do is we're
going to plug in that we want these to
both equal Sigma so I can basically say
now this thing should equal Sigma
squared that's I'm just plugging this
equals Sigma into here and I get these
equals Sigma squared this is really cool
last step okay left inverse by T left
multiplied by T to get rid of this T
inverse and when I get is WC wot equals
T Sigma squared so this should look
really familiar to you this is the
formula for the eigen decomposition this
is my big matrix these are
my eigen vectors and these are my eigen
values and notice that the eigen values
of this product will have to always be
non-negative because this is Sigma
squared so these could sometimes be zero
but they're never going to be negative
okay so this is a diagonal matrix of
non-negative eigen values of the product
WC x wo and these are the eigenvectors
so this is kind of amazing if I had this
is model reduction so I have access to a
B and C if I had access to a B and C I
can build my controllability and
observability graeme ins in those
original coordinates and then what I do
is I do a big egg in decomposition
remember in MATLAB this is super simple
it's just T comma Sigma squared equals i
of WCW oh okay so it's like a one-line
MATLAB command to get T and Sigma
squared now I have that coordinate
transformation that balances my Grammie
ins and I have the Sigma that those
balance crimeans
should equal this is amazing okay all we
did was basically multiply two matrices
and plug in what we want and we came out
at the eigen decomposition this is the
formula for the eigen decomposition hope
everyone gets this so if I had a B and C
I could compute these Graeme ins I could
compute their eigen vectors and that is
the coordinate transformation that
balances my Grammie ins okay that is
almost the whole story I'm going to tell
you about the subtlety the subtlety here
is okay the subtlety is there are lots
of T's I can scale my eigen vectors
let's say it that way I can if I have an
eigen vector and I multiply it by two
it's still an eigen vector so this T is
not exactly unique I could I could do
unit length columns of T and that would
be unique I could kind of normalize the
columns of T that's what normally the I
command does that normalizes these
columns but what's interesting is there
are actually lots of ways that WC x wo
can equal Sigma squared without them
being exactly equal to Sigma let me give
you an example I could have
WC hat equals to Sigma and I could have
wo hat equals 1/2 Sigma and this
expression would still be true and this
eigen decomposition would still be true
but I would have a tea that's off by a
scaling factor because these are not
equal anymore they're off by a factor of
four okay
so the last step the main step the this
is kind of the hands-down the most
important step is multiplying my Grammie
ins and computing the eigen
decomposition the eigenvectors but
there's this very important second step
which is now I have to scale these eigen
vectors to get these to be exactly equal
to each other
okay and I'm just gonna kind of give you
the punchline you can work through all
of the math in fact this is this is in
Chapter 9 of the the book on data-driven
modeling that we just we just wrote
myself and Nathan cuts and so you can go
and verify all of the details either
yourself or in that book I'm just going
to give you the punchline okay so the
punchline is let's say that I have let's
say that I call this my unscaled
eigenvectors okay so my T sub u is just
my unscaled eigenvectors that come out
of out of the MATLAB command and I'm
gonna have to find a scaling that makes
these exactly equal to each other so in
those unscaled coordinates what I have
is tu inverse W si tu minus star is this
new hat Graham Ian let's call that it's
going to be diagonal but it doesn't have
to equal the observability it's gonna be
Sigma control similarly I'm going to
have tu observability Graeme and T u
there's a star here is gonna equal Sigma
oh and remember these are both diagonal
but they might be this might be four
times bigger than that one or four times
smaller or whatever and I'm trying to
now scale this T so that these are equal
to Sigma their product is still Sigma
squared but I want them to both be equal
to Sigma so I get to scale these
eigenvectors to do that now so the the
punchline this is you can verify this
yourself but the the punchline is that
there's this Sigma
s which is Sigma control to the 1/4
times Sigma observable to the 1/4 - ok
and if I take T equals my unscaled T
times Sigma s then if I do this in those
t coordinates
I get WC hat equals wo hat equals Sigma
they're equal to each other there's no
scaling this one isn't 4 times smaller
than that or 3 times smaller or whatever
they're really equal and their products
still equals Sigma squared ok I want to
recap most important thing most
important thing there is a coordinate
transformation T that takes my
controllability and observability graeme
in and makes them equal and diagonal and
it's given by this eigen decomposition
of their product which is amazing ok you
can compute this in MATLAB pretty easily
now if I naively do this there's lots of
T matrices there's lots of scalings of
these eigenvectors t that will give me
controllability and observability Graham
Ian's whose product is Sigma squared but
they're off by a scaling so I have to
rescale my eigenvectors using this Sigma
s which is some funky quarter power of
blah blah blah whatever it's just a
rescaling of these columns of T and then
I get these to be exactly equal and
diagonal and then what's really cool is
if I have this equal and diagonal T
matrix here T ok the first column is the
most controllable state direction and
the most observable it's the most
jointly controllable and observable
state direction the second one is the
second most and essentially what I can
do is if I want a model reduction I can
chop off all but the first let's say
five columns of T and now I have a model
in terms of five variables that captures
it's guaranteed to capture most of that
input output energy okay that's really
cool so that's where we're gonna go next
we're going to use this this is called
the balancing transformation really
important this is the balancing
transformation
and what we're gonna do next two things
I'm gonna code this up in MATLAB and
we're going to convince you that there's
no magic this all works and we can get
these eigen decomposition zand we can do
this balancing transformation so we're
going to do a MATLAB example this is
going to become a plot the second thing
we're going to do is we're going to use
this balancing transformation this is a
square matrix and we're gonna truncate
all but the first our columns to get a
reduced order model over here okay
that's what more did that's what we're
gonna do that's all coming up next
thank you